99 of businesses end up closing down
over a long enough time horizon only one
percent of businesses ever get sold or
trained chance and the reason for that
is not because you know the the what you
might think right you might think that
it's because business owners don't know
how to sell their business or don't know
how to market the business to get sold
but that's actually not the real reason
the real reason is because most
businesses are worthless and so what i
want to talk about today is how to go
from a worthless business
to a business that has actual value
hi my name's alex from joseon
acquisition.com we're in a portfolio
company that has 85 million a year and i
have nothing to sell you all right and
so my goal here at this channel is that
there's a lot of people who are broke
and i don't want you to be one of them
all right and so right now if you're a
small business owner um which you know
there's 30 million small businesses or
whatever it is a lot most of these
businesses don't actually have value and
the reason for that is because they are
not businesses they are they are jobs
right and so if you remember robert
kiyosaki's uh
his his wealth quadrant i think it goes
employee self-employed uh owner and then
and then investor i believe that's the
quadrant i could be wrong but i'm pretty
sure that's what it is at least that's
how i would draw it in my head in terms
of some progression so most of us have
you know most people have jobs first
right and then they make a certain
amount of money they're relatively
skilled and they think you know i could
do something like this on my own right
or i could do something else on my own
and so then they switch to self-employed
and what they don't know is that switch
from box one to box two is that you
actually take a decrease in pay and the
re the reason for that is because you
actually aren't that good yet you know
how to do one thing well here and
because of that because you fit into a
larger machine you're able to earn
higher pay because as a as a sum of
parts uh you can actually provide more
value right but when you actually have
to be each of the parts you're not that
good at it yet and so you become
self-employed and you actually make
significantly less for a long period of
time the thing is is that most people
who are self-employed have an llc right
and so they consider themselves to be
business owners but the reality is that
they are not business owners they are
self-employed and even if you have other
employees that work for you
you were still self-employed here's the
litmus test for this right
what happens is and i have these
conversations all the time because
there's companies that apply to to
become portfolio companies uh with us so
we can invest in the companies and help
them help them grow and that's just for
fyi it's when you're over five million
bucks a year so if you're not there then
don't worry about all this stuff is free
so just consume it all right the the
thing that happens though is that they
stop doing the actual fulfillment of the
thing whatever the widget is whether
whatever they're selling right where the
service is they're not actually doing
the fulfillment and so in that moment
they're like i now own a business and
i'm a business owner and now i can sell
this business and that's so far from the
truth because there are so many other
things that must happen right in order
for a business to be sellable because
for business to be sellable it must be
an asset they can run without you now
you might think again here's the fallacy
that your business can run without you
and that's because maybe you don't do
the actual thing but you are still
involved in maybe the marketing and the
sales right if you can't get someone to
replace you in that then you can't sell
it now you might think i'll just sell
and then somebody else will do that
it's not going to be a sellable thing no
one's going to do that because they're
like well you haven't done it well why
would i believe that someone can do it
besides you because you haven't proved
it and so what you have to do is prove
to what a future buyer would be that
this business can operate on its own
without you right
and so the next step right is that you
replace the acquisition so first you
have the services that you're not doing
then you replace the acquisition process
to be something that is reliable
pick one of the channels you want you
could pick referrals you could pick
affiliates you could pick uh manual
outbound which is cold calls called
emails whatever you could pick uh owned
media which is like all the people that
you already have contact with that you
can message you could have uh earned
media which is that you you start
creating a channel of your own that that
a platform will distribute your content
that's how you generate a business or
you could do paid traffic right you
could you could do paid media and start
running ads on a consistent way to
generate sales right no matter what it
is you have to have a consistent process
where you know if you put x effort or x
dollars in this side that you will get y
outcome on the other side right
and if you don't have that then you
don't have a sellable business now
here's what happens next so
first you you productize your service so
it's a consistent thing that you deliver
it over and over again you're not custom
if it's custom it's gonna be terrible
and it's gonna be it's gonna be valued
as a service-based business which is
gonna suck and you're not gonna be able
to sell it you're gonna have a massive
earn out which basically means you're
gonna work for the next five years to
earn the exact same pay except you no
longer own the business and the person
who gives you the earn out has all the
upside and you you take all the risk and
they got all the upside so no bueno
there and so you've prioritized the
service you you you're you have a
predictable acquisition process right
and you're like now i can sell the
business ah wait there's more because
the thing is is that you still
own all the hats you still might be
managing the sales team you might still
be managing the marketing you stop it
might be innovating the product you
still might be making uh all the chief
decisions right you still might even be
operating the business just not actually
doing any of those things and so to say
that like i am now a business owner and
this this works without me is not true
you were just you were doing higher
level skills which believe it or not are
more expensive to replace believe it you
know and so now you have to go find
someone who's going to become your vp of
sales so you can take that hat off and
who's going to become your your your
director of marketing so you can take
that hat off and who's going to become
the the chief product guy who's going to
be consistently innovating the product
and improving it so that it you know
delivers excess value to your customers
right so you have all these hats on and
so the process of entrepreneurship of
transitioning from self-employed where
you literally have a hundred hats
right to transition your business owner
where you take all the hats off your
head and you were just a shareholder
which is how i prefer to see it it's
like you have to think of yourself not
as the owner but as the director of the
board as the as the as the chief
shareholder in the company right rather
than the owner okay even even that
change in language i think is helpful
and it was for me what we have to do
here and if you're like man that's gonna
take a long time to do that
duh that's why most businesses don't get
sold and that's why sometimes it takes
years to build something that's great
right it might take you three years
might take you five years it might take
you ten years right to get the business
at that point and if you're like man if
i only just had xyz insert person i
could do this welcome to
entrepreneurship like the game is about
people right once you have the model and
you have some of the tactics in the
beginning so you can get some initial
traction like the rest of it is people
right people are the thing that are
gonna run this machine for you and that
means you have to learn how to recruit
have to how to hire how to manage and
how to lead right and those are the soft
skills that are harder to to um
uh they're less tangible but they're
just as important if not more so right
when you look at the the biggest
billionaires and multi-millionaires out
there they have they keep their their
their space around them very clean they
know what they stand for they know and
people are attracted to them because
they have admirable qualities and traits
and that is how you get the higher level
people so think about this so let's say
that you've got somebody who who's a
who's a brilliant marketer who can
generate demand like crazy for you right
well that person isn't going to work for
someone who's lower skilled than they
are
right you have to have more skills to
attract the type of people that you want
who are going to help you run this
business and grow it because they have
to believe in the vision they want to do
something that's meaningful
and so um the the journey here is
understanding and this is the piece that
i think most people miss is that they
don't even know the hats that they are
wearing you making decisions is a hat
it's an important hat
right and so selling it without the
person who can make decisions isn't a
business right if you're selling it and
you're still the chief chief marketing
officer you're the one who's controlling
the messaging and the branding and all
of those things
it's still like that that
that role still exists
and so there's typically far more
leadership that has to occur in order
for the business to be sellable and
here's the thing now all of a sudden all
of these roles that you've been doing
up to this point you've been taking
profit profit sell discretionary
earnings sde right from the business
when in reality a lot of that profit
must be allocated back to the roles that
you're doing but you're not choosing to
pay yourself for right what happens is a
business will become more sellable
as you replace all of the pieces that
you're doing and oftentimes the margin
will drop but that is okay because now
you have 100 of your time back and then
you are truly a shareholder in the
company and this takes years not months
not weeks and the thing is is you're
going to hire somebody who you think is
going to be good at marketing and
they're not going to be and then you
have to hire another person and then you
think they're going to be good at
marketing and they're not then you got
to hire another person right and if
you're like man that sounds tiring
that's the reason most people who own
big companies are like it is hard to do
this this is not easy this is not for
the faint of heart you must have a
long-term vision that you are committed
to because you will burn out if you're
only doing it for the money you will
because once you've satisfied your
personal needs you'll just stop being
you'll stop being inspired by the reason
that you're doing this right and the
thing is is your employees will be even
less inspired because all of it starts
with you and then gets diluted down and
so if you are not extremely potent right
you are not extremely distilled down in
terms of your vision of where you want
to go and why you're doing this why this
business even exists then other people
be even less so and less committed to
that vision and you will attract lower
quality people and they will they will
turn out and they will not be skilled
etc what happens is
the small businesses become big
businesses because you need to slowly
grow them so that you can accommodate
more people right who can actually do
all of the things that you do and the
reality is that you're not going to find
because right now you're like well
there's one of me so i just need to hire
one more person but that's not that's
not reality right you might be doing six
things and you might have to hire six
people to do what you are doing and of
course you do and that sounds
unreasonable but welcome to business and
so for businesses to be scalable
oftentimes they have to have significant
enough gross margins
and volume to be able to uh pay for high
quality talent to be able to actually do
these things to take decisions off your
plate and where you get into the point
of kind of like hyper growth and
hyperscale where you're starting to talk
10 million 20 million 30 million plus
per year right is when you have people
who come with solutions pre-loaded they
come with experience of having done the
thing that you need to solve already so
this like you'll notice the transition
the business owner and i'll tell you
this right now is that once you start
crossing multiple eight figures the
people that you are hiring are better
than you are
at everything
and that's one of the that's one of the
that's one of the weird things that
happens because in the beginning most
people don't have the skills that you do
right and so you have to hire people who
are not as good as you are and then you
have to train them right and then later
on you start hiring people who are okay
at some things you still have to train
them on how you want it done so they
have they've done the type of role in
the business in the past but they don't
know how you want it done here so you
have some training but there's less and
there's some experience right
the level above that is when people come
in they know what to do they know how to
do it better better than you for your
specific business and when that happens
then you realize how how little utility
you actually have in the business
and how your really only role is to just
recruit people right recruit people and
and cast the vision of where you or want
to make the bet for the company of where
you want it to go
and so anyways
the reason that most businesses are
worthless is because they sell entirely
customized things they sell to everyone
which makes it completely unscalable
they're the ones who are still heavily
involved in the acquisition in the rain
making and so because of that um and
then even then even after they've
graduated from getting out of the
selling and getting out of the
fulfillment the the business still
doesn't have value because they might
still be the talking face they still may
be the spokesperson which means that the
the business has no value outside of
themselves because no one else could
take it over right unless the person
agreed to a three or five year earn out
which then means that you transfer the
ownership to someone else they get all
the upside and if you don't hit the
milestones they get your business
anyways and you get none of the money
right and so it may sound arduous to do
this and it is but i can tell you that
having now gone through this process it
is one of the most worthwhile things
that you can do is look at the business
as a true sellable asset because i heard
this from i heard this quote
from an mit dude who spoke from john
warlow's book but anyways uh he said all
of you guys are busy selling your
services what you should be doing is
selling your business right you as the
ceo or the owner your job is to sell the
business the job of the of the sales
people is to sell the products right
once you can make the transition from
your businesses or your products rather
than your services of the business are
the products you look you move up in a
level of um
an order of magnitude right
and so i'm not saying that you should
immediately be selling your business
right but you should be making your
business sell a bull and the beauty of
this is that when you go through this
process you end up having phenomenal
leverage in any kind of negotiation that
you want to have in the future and this
is a a key hack for negotiating fyi is
that don't need the deal
the guy who needs to deal the less is
the way that you negotiate like that is
like everyone wants all these tricks and
tactics and things for negotiating the
way to have the way to have the best
negotiation is to have the most leverage
the way to have the most leverage does
not need the deal
simple right simple not easy how about
that and so if you want to sell your
business someday for a lot of money then
the business must be sellable and in
order for you to do that you must get
the business to the point where you
don't even mind keeping it because it's
still cash flow so much money to you and
you don't do anything
that is the position of fu that is the
position where you'll get the most money
because now you have something that
people want no one wants a business
where the owners you know no one wants
to buy themselves a job right and they
don't want to buy themselves your job
and so you have to think and this is the
critical self-awareness of thinking like
what are the actual things that i do
everyone likes to think oh no i don't do
anything this thing ruins itself except
if you step away and didn't answer calls
for two months with the business store
on itself probably not right so then we
have to look at what are we actually
doing and it might be little little
fractional things that we're doing all
over the place but we still have to
quantify those things and we still have
to put processes around them and then
hand them to people and see how they do
and then continue to improve them until
eventually you get to that promised land
where you don't actually have to do
anything
and you can still own the business and i
mean to prove this like you can probably
own shares of companies on the public
traded market they have figured this out
right and you can own a piece
and participate in the upside without
ever ever looking at what apple is doing
for their for their roadmap right and so
we have to get to that point as business
owners in order to make the asset that
we own the most valuable thing that we
have probably the biggest thing on our
net worth balance sheet is all the the
equity that we have in our businesses
and to increase the value of that equity
we have to make it so that it actually a
business and we transition from employee
to self-employed to owner right and then
the transition there goes from owner to
investor because when you make that
transition that is when you start seeing
your business for what it is which is a
sellable asset that sits on your net
worth balance sheet all right and so uh
this is one of the hardest lessons that
took me the longest amount of time to
learn i'm hopefully just translating
this to you because i i see so many
people who are like i want to sell my
business but the business is not
sellable and it is worthless without
them and so we can't just say oh the
next person's going to figure it out
because they're not going to i'll tell
you right now they're not going to you
have to figure it out and what most
people do instead is they just start
another business because they don't know
how to solve the problem and so we must
confront the problems that we have which
is you have to articulate the thing that
you don't know how to do as a problem
that you can solve which is i don't know
how to insert find hire direct a
marketing director i do know how to find
a vp of sales uh and train them and
manage them and grow them i do not know
how to find a chief you know product
officer who's going to innovate the
product on my behalf and make it better
than i ever could and make a better
product and make a better client
experience around and consistently
improve it based on these metrics
until we can articulate what the
problems are we cannot solve them and if
we consistently live in this world of
like i just want to sell my business
someday you're not going to be able to
until you put these pieces in place so
that the business is sellable and
actually has value in and of itself
separate from you and then when that
happens your net worth will skyrocket
because now you have something that
everyone wants which is an asset that
produces cash while you sleep so anyways
uh my name is oxford mosey own
acquisition.com which portfolio company
says 85 million a year i have nothing to
sell you keeping awesome if you like
this hit the subscribe button uh if you
didn't like this i love you either way
and i'll see you guys next video bye